herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen der deutsche bundestag tritt
heute zusammen nachdem gestern
empfindliche einschränkungen der
freiheit beschlossen worden sind diese
entscheidungen betreffen millionen
menschen sie haben auswirkungen auf das
soziale miteinander und die
wirtschaftliche zukunft des landes
sie wurden getroffen ohne öffentlichkeit
und nur von regierungsspitzen aber sie
binden 16 bzw 17 koalitionsregierungen
und legislative der deutsche bundestag
kann diesen beschluss nur noch
nachträglich zur kenntnis nehmen solche
entscheidungsprozesse gefährt nicht nur
die akzeptanz der korona maßnahmen
sie enthalten auch erhebliche rechtliche
risiken und drohen unsere
parlamentarische demokratie zu
reformieren
man kann
man kam zu dem schluss kommen dass
weitreichende grundrechts
einschränkungen die bewegungsfreiheit
die ausübung des berufs notwendig sind
um die pandemie zu kontrollieren
diese entscheidungen sollten hier aber
nicht nur kommentiert sondern nach
harter argumentative auseinandersetzung
in öffentlicher sitzung und gesetzlich
getroffen werden frau merkel
frau merkel sie haben gesagt debatte
stärke die demokratie das ist richtig
dafür muss die debatte aber vor der
entscheidung stattfinden und der orte
entscheidung nicht das parlament sein
die pandemie ist leider zum alltag und
die notlage zur normalität geworden und
deshalb gehört die pandemie bekämpfung
zurück in die parlamente
alle fraktionen dieses hauses sehen
inzwischen diese notwendigkeit außer der
unionsfraktion alle auch mit hoher
dringlichkeit die dazu notwendige
gemeinsame interfraktionelle initiative
sollten wir nicht erst irgendwann
sondern umgehend und aus der mitte
dieses hauses ergreifen was pandemie
geschehen in deutschlands ist dynamisch
wissen alle in sorge um die gesundheit
unserer angehörigen und freunde oder um
die eigene es ist richtig die zahl
unserer kontakte zu verringern und
abstände einzuhalten
das infektionsgeschehen muss durch
wirksame regional ausgerichtete und
verhältnismäßige maßnahmen eingedämmt
werden frau merkel hat mehrfach betont
die beschlüsse des gestrigen tages seien
erforderlich geeignet und
verhältnismäßig diese feststellung
alleine reicht nicht das muss mit
argumenten untermauert werden
denn schließlich
denn schließlich werden nun
beispielsweise auch gastronomiebetriebe
hotels freizeit und kultureinrichtungen
sowie kosmetikstudios geschlossen
übernachtungsangebote werden massiv
eingeschränkt sport wird eingeschränkt
es werden damit bereiche geschlossen die
eben nicht regelmäßig als
infektionsträger aufgefallen sind
sondern die nötigen falls sogar eine
nachverfolgung ihrer gäste sicherstellen
könnten
wenn durch ihre schließung wenn durch
ihre schließung menschen in
unkontrollierte graubereiche gedrängt
werden dann ist für die bekämpfung der
pandemie nichts gewonnen ganz im
gegenteil
es schließen wieder pauschal und
flächendeckend betriebe
nachdem die pauschalen beherbergungs
verbote gerade erst von gerichten
verworfen worden sind die regierungen
gehen damit erneut rechtliche risiken
ein
die berechenbarkeit staatlichen handelns
darf aber nicht fortwährend in frage
gestellt werden der start der staat hat
es bisher zu oft nicht vermocht die
infektionsrisiken von unkontrollierten
massenveranstaltungen zu unterbinden
in berlin wurde die unterstützung durch
die bundeswehr abgelehnt obwohl
gesundheitsämter personell am limit
arbeiten widersinnige regeln haben den
familienurlaub von rügen nach rhodos
umgelenkt der gestrige tag hat zudem
gezeigt dass die politik es nicht
erreicht hat sich auf die absehbar
steigenden fallzahlen im herbst
vorzubereiten
viele betriebe hingegen haben in hygiene
konzepte investiert viele menschen haben
sich sorgsam auf den herbst vorbereitet
diese menschen zahlen jetzt den preis
dafür
dass der stab es nicht genauso getan hat
viele schließungen sind deshalb für den
gesundheitsschutz nicht nur unnötig sie
sind gegenüber den menschen und firmen
für die von der schließung betroffenen
gewährt die regierung eine
außerordentliche wirtschaftshilfe
sie wird nolens volens genutzt werden
sie ist aber nur ein schwacher trost
denn die menschen wollen nicht dauerhaft
finanzhilfe vom staat sie wollen
arbeiten und öffnen und das sollten sie
überall dort dürfen wo der
gesundheitsschutz möglich ist wenn
schäden der krisenpolitik immer weiter
mit schulden kompensiert werden müssen
wird selbst dieser staat an die grenze
seiner finanziellen handlungsfähigkeit
und in den schuldensumpf geführt die
folgen für soziale sicherheit sozialen
frieden und den wohlstand würden wir
jahrzehnte spüren und deshalb ist eine
umkehr notwendig dieses land sollte
seine ressourcen nicht einsetzen dem
stillstand zu finanzieren
wir müssen sie einsetzen um öffentliches
kulturelles und wirtschaftliches leben
zu ermöglichen
die jetzt beschlossenen maßnahmen wirken
sich im übrigen nicht nur bei den
unmittelbar betroffenen aus die
mittelbaren nebenwirkungen werden wir im
handel und bei der
investitionsbereitschaft in der ganzen
volkswirtschaft sehen die aktuelle
wicklung der kapitalmärkte es darf er
nur ein indiz
dieser zweite lockt und sollte daher der
anlass sein die standortattraktivität
deutschlands insgesamt anzugehen
vorschläge zum verzicht auf bürokratie
zur beschleunigung von
investitionsvorhaben oder zur
steuerlichen entlastung haben wir
eingebracht aber eine maßnahme habe hier
vor
es ist dringlich die volle verrechnung
der verluste dieses jahres bei der
steuer mit den gewinnen mindestens der
beiden vorjahre umgehend zu ermöglichen
das land wartet auf diese zielgerichtete
unbürokratische sicherung der
zahlungsfähigkeit von solo
selbstständigen bis hin zur industrie
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
unabhängig davon wie wir die aktuellen
maßnahmen einzeln bewerten hoffen wir
mit ihnen dass sie im ergebnis zumindest
die aktuelle welle brechen können aber
was kommt danach
was passiert im dezember darauf haben
wir bislang keine antwort gehört der
impfstoff er wird dann noch nicht
verfügbar sein und selbst wäre er es
werden wir noch länger mit corona leben
müssen was passiert also wenn nach den
weihnachtsferien die fallzahlen erneut
steigen dann im januar mit der dritten
welle auch der dritte lockdown und dann
später die vierte welle mit dem vierten
lockdown sollen irgendwann das
kolportierte zitat aus unionskreisen zu
verwenden sollen irgendwann die zügel so
stark angezogen werden dass auch die
wohnungsdurchsuchungen aus der
vorstellungswelt bestimmter mitglieder
dieses hauses durchgeführt werden die
unverletzlichkeit der wohnung ist ein
grundrecht und wem unsere
verfassungsordnung heilig ist der stellt
das nicht in frage
es ist nun zeit dass dieses land vom
aktionistischen krisenmanagement zu
einer nachhaltigen und dauerhaft durch
haltbaren risikostrategie wechselt im
märz musste kurzfristig gehandelt werden
im sommer schien der start überrascht
von urlaubsheimkehrer und jetzt von
saisonal steigenden fallzahlen jedesmal
showdown sitzungen jedesmal
aktionistische und teils in sich
widersprüchliche maßnahmen mag dieser
zweite lok tor auch milder sein als der
erste es muss nun der letzte gewesen
sein
gestern liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
hat ein beachtlicher teil der
organisierten ärztinnen und ärzte
zusammen mit namhaften experten bedenken
gegenüber ihren beschlüssen geäußert es
wurden andere vorschläge für die
bewältigung dieser krise vorgelegt frau
bundeskanzlerin dieser gruppe kann und
darf man nicht populismus oder
unkenntnis unterstellen nur weil sie zu
anderen abwägungen kommen als sie diese
gruppe diese gurke diese gruppe setzt
auf gebote statt verbote um an die
selbstverantwortung der bürgerinnen und
bürger zu appellieren und der gewöhnung
an panik vokabular vorzubeugen
sie regen die konzentration der
ressourcen auf die bevölkerungsgruppen
an die ein hohes risiko für schwere
krankheitsverläufe haben im gestrigen
beschluss ist dass nur einer von 16
punkten der im übrigen heute von der
frau bundeskanzlerin noch einmal
relativiert worden ist systematische
tests und masken mit höchsten
schutzniveau können aber menschenleben
retten und zugleich der vereinsamung
unserer eltern und großeltern
entgegenwirken und die gruppe schlägt
ein bundesweit einheitliches ampel
system vor das regional differenzierte
maßnahmen nachvollziehbar macht diese
anregungen könnten basis eine um eines
umgangs mit der pandemie seien der hand
und sicherheit bietet
der dauerhaft durchhaltbar ist und der
uns von aktionismus befreit
aber selbst dann wenn man diese
vorschläge nicht oder zumindest nicht
sofort teilt belegen sie eines die
krisenpolitik der regierung ist nicht
alternativlos eine vertiefte debatte
über alternativen zu den beispiellosen
freiheits einschränkungen dieser tage
findet hier im zentrum unserer
demokratie indessen nicht hinreichend
statt
aber jeder vorschlag der
gesundheitsschutz und freiheit in eine
bessere balance bringt als ihre politik
hätte eine ernsthafte und ergebnisoffene
prüfung verdient
[Applaus]